[SPEAKER_00]: I do this for many reasons, but since the whale sun into the seventh whale sun, Gouge's thoughts on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wondering what our next move is on this due to the fact
[SPEAKER_01]: That everything's gone sideways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wondering if we were brought here intentionally to be assassinated through someone commanding Owen to have this done, take us, and get rid of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or he's working on his own, which is highly doubtful, and no idea what to expect going along with going to the castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so I'm going to start with the first thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Earl of Retro is the enemy of Monmurg, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's no way you want to put yourself in that guy's power.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: The way the men-at-arms and the knight were acting, it's like they were trying to quell, enforce
[SPEAKER_00]: They were looking for Owen, so you're not totally sure that he's working with them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe they tolerated him up to a point, and whatever happened in the chart room, they were like, hey buddy, is this you?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not going to tolerate this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or possibly...
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen tipped him off about you.
[SPEAKER_01]: It didn't say... Because he knows me.
[SPEAKER_00]: We go back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or he didn't say, oh, this is me.
[SPEAKER_00]: He basically said there are some smugglers here.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're on this boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because they went to this boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: They didn't go to where he was.
[SPEAKER_00]: So whatever the case, they came to this place.
[SPEAKER_00]: They knew to come to the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: And why would they know that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe somebody saw you come back to the boat and that's why they came?
[SPEAKER_01]: And they were looking for the people that did the deed?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because that was pretty bloody and stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're not really sure there, but it doesn't seem like Owen Black's in league with these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: It doesn't seem like they totally are necessarily in league either.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe they're tolerated?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not really sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be interesting to know these things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Owen tried to get you guys killed, and the question is, why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the Keolander here.
[SPEAKER_01]: How's the blockade going?
[SPEAKER_01]: All the merchant ships are coming in with their goods, but it's a shit show.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they can maybe unload two or four versus Monmurg being able to help 24-7 of this shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: So... What... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is this shit show doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously he's...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not gaining as much as... Yeah, I mean...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's kind of fucked.
[SPEAKER_00]: To your mind, it's more about punishing Monmurg than it is about anything else, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And these people are offloading their wares for cheap for whatever they can get because they know they're screwed, shit's gonna spoil, stuff's...
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, ten of these ships coming to Monmurg was heated for the rest of the year.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is an embargo.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's more political.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's happening, obviously, is the Duke of Gratzel is trying to start Monmurg out.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the burning of Porvin has kind of facilitated that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, whatever happens with the Earl of Red Shore...
[SPEAKER_00]: The question remains, and you guys kind of answered it last time, why isn't the Monmurgian Navy coming over, busting the shit out of those three men of war, which it easily could do, and go on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they can't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they're getting stopped.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're getting blocked by, most likely, the turtles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Turtle or dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: That are being controlled.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they can stop anything, sink anything, create the mist, the fog.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, what happened
[SPEAKER_00]: With Owen Black and Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: He took him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before that, he talked to Folsom too much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Spilled his...got too chummy with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gave him a lot of information.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was going to keep him, but he wanted the rest because he figured Folsom talked to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we need to be quiet.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Owen figured out that you and Merrick, at the very least, were agents and that he talked too much to you guys about Kane Tolley.
[SPEAKER_00]: It wasn't like maybe... it wasn't like he...
[SPEAKER_00]: Wanted to get you out of Monmurg to kill you.
[SPEAKER_00]: He actually was trying to do a deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then after Folsom pumped him for all that information, he was like, oh, I fucked up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got to cover his tracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: So at this point,
[SPEAKER_01]: So we were sent out with Owen to try to figure out what was... What he knew.
[SPEAKER_01]: What he knew.
[SPEAKER_01]: What Owen knew.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was it.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was our... to figure out what Owen knew.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's kind of what James told you in Merrick.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, Owen's back, he's been in Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: We figured out what he's doing, and we did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well Folsom did.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it was a gold mine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because, I mean, you never imagined he would actually know Cain totally, or about this island that Cain has, or about this artifact that he has.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: We gotta get back to Jameis and tell him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think there's any use of going to the castle, the mercenaries.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is way beyond our means of stopping any of this, and it's pointless.
[SPEAKER_01]: We want to break the blockade.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've got to figure out how, with the information that we have, give it to who we need to give it to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let them figure out and let us be the pawns that we are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, do you have anything else you want to say?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to do this with all the guys, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I think I have enough red eyes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.